- All right, to get started,
who hates raising their hands in sessions?
All right, cool.
Now that we got that outta the way.
How many of you have moved at
least five times in your life?
All right. How many have
moved 10 times in your life?
Whoa. All right, so get a load of this.
This is the one thing you're gonna,
like next week you're gonna be like,
"Man, the one thing I
remember from re:Invent,
it's this right here."
Ready? All right.
The average person between age 18 and 45
in the United States has moved 11 times.
I kid you not, you're gonna
wake up a week from now
and you're gonna be like,
"This bald bearded guy told me
that people moved 11 times in their life."
Why do people stop moving
so much after age 45?
- [Attendee] Lifestyle changes.
- Yeah, it's painful.
Your lifestyle changes.
You don't have time for this.
Moving can be a real pain.
- [Attendee] Well, there's one more move.
- One more. Yeah, one more move for sure.
So when we started our
planning for this session,
Aarthi and I were like, you know,
"We really like these sessions to be fun."
We'd like to figure out some way
to actually make this engaging.
So what do we do?
We reach out to our
product marketing person.
I wanted to share with
you some behind the scenes
of how this actually works.
So Aarthi emails Bianca,
our amazing teammate
who works in product
marketing, and she's like,
"Hey, can we get a moving
truck up next to the stage?
You know, we brought the
trucks in the past on stage.
Could we do that?" Bianca's
response was like, "For real?"
And we're like, "Yeah, don't
worry, we won't drive it.
It'll just sit there. Maybe
we can get some moving boxes."
And she was not reassured on this.
All right, so, well, we
couldn't get moving trucks,
we couldn't get boxes.
What do we do? Next
best thing, we used AI.
About 10 prompts later,
I was able to successfully
generate an image
that I thought was great.
A huge thank you to my wife for telling me
what a boho aesthetic is.
I would not have known that.
And my children for saying
that this "High key slays."
So I think we have a
pretty good image here.
So the question you're all asking is,
why in the world am I looking
at an AI generated image of a couch?
The thing I wanna point out
here is when you're moving,
the way that we move this couch
versus the way that we move
the books in the background
versus the way we move
the lamps or the plants,
they're all different.
It's not one-size-fits-all
for how we move all of it.
The new house you're moving into
may not have amazing AI
generated bookshelves
in the background to put
those AI generated books on.
They may have a different layout,
the house may have
different number of rooms,
but it's all different when you're moving
from point A to point B having
to try to figure that out.
Typically it's pretty easy
to actually move the couch.
I say that, you know, not
having moved a couch recently,
but it is pretty easy to move that,
you know, it's a big fixed item.
You can just lift it and you can shift it
into the new location.
Whereas the books, a
lot of the knickknacks
or smaller items, figuring
out where all of those go
in the new house, that part
can take a little bit of time.
So as we talk about
moving, it's the same thing
that really happens when we're talking
about moving our applications
and moving our workloads
from an on-prem
environment into the cloud.
And one thing that we really think about
is that there is not a single path.
There is no single way to move everything
from on prem into the cloud
that makes sense for everybody.
All of you may be at a
completely different place
in your cloud journey.
You may have completely
different types of workloads
that need to move in
completely different ways.
Yes, picking up a VM, moving
it from point A to point B,
that part can work pretty well,
it's pretty straightforward.
But you may have other applications
that are better suited to run
on spot instances within EC2
or even different size
or different capabilities
within those EC2 instances.
You may have cases where you could move
into a serverless architecture,
you could leverage Lambda,
you could leverage EKS,
you could use RDS and move
it into managed services.
The thing here is that
we talk about customers
not being a one-size-fits-all,
like there is no,
we say "This customer's
going to lift and shift."
That's really not the case.
This customer maybe use lift and shift
for certain applications,
or they may be using different
methods as they go along.
When we talk about these methods,
if any of you have ever
seen the AWS articles
about the seven Rs, there's,
you know, the different methods
for actually relocating.
A lot of the methods I showed
here fit into the seven Rs.
You can re-platform, you can refactor,
you can rehost, you can relocate.
There's a lot of different ways
that you can go about
moving these applications
from point A to point B.
And even the point B may
be different in many cases,
point B may still be on premises.
You may be able to use those workloads
or run those workloads within
something like an AWS Outpost,
which can still run in your
on-premises environment.
So let's talk about one way to do that
and that's lifting and shifting
from an on-premises VMware environment
into a cloud-based VMware environment.
So earlier this year,
we launched the Amazon
Elastic VMware Service.
The Elastic VMware Service is the ability
to take and run VMware-based
workloads, the VCF stack
directly in your Amazon, your AWS VPC.
So just like how you
would run an EC2 instance
within your BPC and connect
it to the environment,
you can now run VMware stack
directly on AWS metal infrastructure
sitting within that environment.
So this is the same VMware stack
that you would run in your
on-premises environment.
It's not something special,
it's not some modified version.
We literally take the commercial
off-the-shelf capabilities,
the commercial off-the-shelf software
and we run that within AWS
VPCs within the environment
so that you're able to move
from point A to point B
without having to change the
people skills that you have,
the processes and
runbooks that they operate
and the technology that they use,
whether that be third-party
solutions or scripts.
So from a basic feature perspective,
I mentioned that this is
running the standard BCF stack.
So we take Cloud Builder, which
is a part of the BCF stack,
we gather a bunch of
information from you upfront.
We say, "Hey, tell me
about the underlay networks
that you wanna run.
Tell me about the number of hosts
that you want in the environment."
We collect a bunch of
information from you upfront
through the AWS Console.
We take that information
and we actually bootstrap
the metal instances
and we push the configuration
into Cloud Builder
and then let Cloud Builder
deploy the VMware stack.
So in VCF, it's basically
just like how you would take
those old-school CDs that used to have
the pre-configured
configuration for VMware
and you pop it in and the
server kind of brings itself up.
It's very similar to
that in the cloud world,
where you give us a bunch of
information ahead of time,
we'll take that, we'll
bootstrap the environment,
we'll pass the information
to Cloud Builder.
It'll run and configure the environment,
we hand you back the credentials
and we say, "Here's the credentials."
Now you can log in and
you're running VMware
on EC2 instances within your BPC.
You can interface with this
through both the AWS Console and the API.
So if you were to go into your AWS Console
and look for the EVS, you would
actually find that service
and you could go in and
deploy an environment
and get started today.
I did mention we're
running on EC2 instances.
These are i4i.metal instances,
so this is bare metal, this
is not nested virtualization
or any kind of, you know, vert
on vert or special hardware
sitting off in the corner
of our data centers.
This is standard EC2 metal infrastructure
with the i4i.metal instances.
Today we do run VCF 5.2.1
and you do have access
to SCDC manager, vCenter,
all the normal VMware tools
that you would run on prem,
you can access those in EVS.
So a really simple way
of thinking about this
is it's almost like using
AWS metal infrastructure,
like a co-location environment,
but you're able to dynamically
scale up and down those servers
with the click of a button
as opposed to ordering more hardware.
You do have full administrative rights
so we do not run this
as a managed service.
This is completely controlled
by you, the customer.
Just like if you were doing it
in an on-premises environment.
You have full admin access.
You can get and do really
just about anything
in this environment that you could do
in an on-premises environment.
From a consumption perspective,
you do have the ability
to deploy instances using
instant savings plans.
So if you wanted to commit
at a one year interval
or consume on demand or
even three year intervals,
you do have flexibility and choice
as far as how you consume those instances.
And we do operate in a
bring-your-own subscription model.
Going forward, kind of
in all cloud providers
running VMware, it is a
bring-your-own subscription model.
So you can take the
existing VCF subscriptions
that you have on premises,
you can bring those with you
and you can apply those and use those
into the EVS environment.
And then choice, you do have the ability
to run these yourself or
you can engage a partner.
We worked with a lot of partners
who have built managed
services where they can come in
and operate this for you in AWS
just like you would do in
an on-premises environment.
From a scale perspective, we
launched EVS back in August
and we had six regions available.
We're now up to 12 regions
and we're continuing to launch
more regions later this year
as well as going into next year.
So you'll continue to see us
work in getting EVS launched
into all AWS regions
over the next few months.
I mentioned briefly kind
of the customer managed
versus partner managed.
This is a big deal for a lot of customers
who are maybe moving to
the cloud and they have had
on-premises managed
service provider partners
that they were using
who are no longer a part
of Broadcom's managed
service provider program.
In that case, you are
able to move into EVS
and leverage third-party partners
who are still in that program.
They have a lot of expertise
with running in EC2 environments
running inside of AWS,
and they have a lot of expertise
running in VMware environments.
And so there's just a lot of partners
that you can leverage to do that
or you have the choice to do it yourself.
The big thing here is there's
a lot of offerings out there
that force you into a managed model.
They force to say, "Hey, you don't have
full administrative access.
You're operating in a delegated model."
In our case, we have built this
as a customer-managed solution first.
So by default you have
access to everything
and then you can bring in a partner
if you would like them to run
and operate the environment
on your behalf.
Quickly just mentioning
some of those partners,
it's not just the managed
service provider partners
like that we have here shown at the top,
but also on the ISV side.
A lot of the tools that you use
in your on-premises data centers
will operate just the same way in EVS.
Think of things like NetApp
or Pure Storage or Veeam.
A common thing we used to
hear from customers is,
"Hey, when I moved to the cloud,
it's not just about moving the workloads.
I have to now suddenly reevaluate
all these solutions that I'm using.
My backup provider, my DR provider,
I have my security tools,
like all these things
that I've built and integrated
into my environment.
I now have to reevaluate
how I'm going to do those in the cloud."
When you lift and shift with
EVS, pick up those workloads,
move them from VMware to
VMware, you can keep the people,
the processes and the
technology exactly the same
as what you had on premises
because you're still using
a VMware environment.
So kind of going back
to that moving metaphor
that we talked about in the beginning.
Imagine you have a house,
and your house is kind of out
in the country a little bit
and you have a whole bunch of land.
So you have a whole
bunch of space available
to where if you wanted to
build things, you could.
You could build a bakery,
you could build a store,
you could build whatever you wanted.
You have tons of space, but ultimately,
you have to build it yourself.
Now think about moving into a destination
where you're a part of a vibrant village,
a community that has all of
these things already in there.
You already have a baker,
you already have a grocer,
there is a hardware shop.
All of these things exist in this village
and now it's walkable.
You can just walk over and
interface with these things
without having to go
and build it yourself.
That's really the way
you think about scaling
and operating in a VMware
environment in AWS.
You're taking the same
house, the same floor plan,
everything that you had before
and you're able to move
that into a community
that now has all of
these other capabilities.
So you can take this workload
that you are running in VMware
and now it's sitting in your VPC,
you have RDS that you're
running in your VPC,
you have S3, you have EFS,
you have all these
other cloud capabilities
that are now sitting co-resident
in the same environment
with your VMware-based workloads.
And we see a lot of customers do this.
They'll take a database for example
that's running inside of VMware
and they may move that over to RDS,
but the application
itself is still running
in VMware on a VM.
If the application is really,
really hard to transform
or modernize or change,
we are totally fine
with being able to have you
run that workload in VMware.
In fact, if you have workloads
that you plan on keeping in VMware,
we want to be the best place in the world
for you to run those
VMware-based workloads.
If, when you move that into the cloud,
you want to expand and
extend that application
to be able to interface
with other AWS workloads,
we want you to have
that capability as well.
All right, I'm gonna
hand it over to Aarthi
and she's gonna talk a little bit
about the building blocks of EVS.
- Thank you Andy.
While our product marketing person
was not able to get us
the couch or the truck,
we got a good Monday session
that I requested for.
And the primary reason
is what I'll be doing the next few minutes
is talking about the
three key building blocks
that make up the service.
This is an introductory-level session
and then we have some great
deeper dives throughout the week
that you can go in and plug into
as you wanna learn more about the storage
or networking, et cetera.
Andy touched upon this,
I wanna spend a couple of minutes here.
When EVS deploys the VCF stack,
we get inputs from you,
and if you've deployed
a Cloud Builder on VCF stack
on premises, you would see
that the Cloud Builder
requires certain inputs
and that's all the service is doing.
We collect all these inputs from you
and take care of the deployment.
It is a fully self-managed service
minus the initial deployment.
We wanted to kind of remove
that deployment from you
and take care of it on behalf of you.
So when the stack is deployed,
you get all these components
deployed, from SDDC manager
to the ESXI hypervisor,
to storage, to networking.
But we also take care,
and as you'll see when we talk
about the building blocks,
the underlying connectivity
and storage options for you,
depending on your use case
and your application needs.
When we deploy the stack,
we deploy it in a single
consolidated domain.
But of course there's flexibility for you
as you deploy more hosts
and you can bring up additional clusters,
you can do multiple workload domains.
We deploy, I kept saying we deploy,
EVS service deploys
the environment for you
in your AWS account in
a VPC that you choose.
So obviously from a security standpoint,
the AWS shared responsibility
model is still applicable.
Where it varies is we as
an AWS are responsible
for the underlying AWS
components that you see here.
So this means from a region
availability standpoint
or an availability zone
standpoint, we take care of that.
We also take care of capacity for you.
So you place in a capacity
request reservation
saying, "Hey, I need 10
hosts by a specific date."
And we enable that
capacity into your account.
But anything upward of the hyper wise
of the ESXI stack upwards
is your responsibility.
This means you are responsible
for patching your environment,
you're responsible for updates, et cetera.
There's three key building
blocks that I kept mentioning.
The first one obviously is compute.
We started with i4i.metal
as our first instance type.
This is a bare metal instance
where we deploy the environment on.
We have a good history with i4i.metal.
For some of you who are familiar
with the VMware cloud on
AWS, the managed service,
we utilized i4i.metal.
We've received good
feedback from customers
across various use cases
of their applications.
These instances also go
through a full certification
with Broadcom.
So today, if you go into the
Broadcom Compatibility Guide,
you will see Amazon i4i.metal
listed as a certified instance
to run VCF 5.2.1.
So we do go through the
entire service certification,
storage and network
certification with Broadcom.
We launched with one instance type
and our goal is eventually
to get every metal instance
that's available on the AWS
portfolio available for you
so you can choose based on,
"Hey, I do have a high-memory workload
so I need more memory versus compute."
So that's our goal and
it's on our roadmap.
Andy talked about scaling.
So if you think about how do
you scale this environment
that we deploy, think of the
EVS stack that we deploy,
the environment as a top level construct.
Within the environment,
we take care of that first
cluster that you see here.
It's a four host minimum.
This comes from the VCF
requirement that we have
and every environment
can have up to 16 hosts.
We've tested up to 16 hosts
and are satisfied with the performance
and we are slowly expanding
this number of hosts soon as well.
You could have up to 16 hosts
and you could have this as
multiple clusters as well
within that environment.
If you have a requirement to
scale beyond 16 hosts today,
you could obviously create
multiple environments
and these environments can
communicate to each other
using a transit gateway.
The next building block is storage.
The i4i.metal instances
come with 30 tebibytes
of local NVME storage,
which is what we use
for the primary storage,
which is vSAN in this case.
We are using the ESA, the
express storage architecture,
which gives a better performance
compared to the OSA architecture.
So vSAN forms the primary
storage that is available.
What we've also had
feedback from customers
is, "Hey, I wanna make
sure this is consistent
with my on-premises experience."
And so if you're doing
storage policy-based
management on premises,
you want to control what
your rate levels are
or what your failure to tolerance is,
all that's still possible.
You could log to your vCenter console
once the environment is deployed for you
and you can configure these
as you would do on premises.
One of the feedback we've received
when we started running private preview
and then we moved into a public preview
is scalability on storage.
Not a lot of workloads need that compute,
but are more storage intensive.
So we've partnered with
our internal service,
the Amazon FSx for NetApp ONTAP
as an additional storage option.
The primary storage is still vSAN,
but you could create
additional data stores
using NetApp ONTAP.
Or Andy talked, you have
full administrative access
to this EVS environment,
which means if you are using
ISV solutions on premises
like Veeam or Pure Cloud
Storage for example,
you have the ability to integrate
with these storage vendors as well
depending on your application needs.
So if you take a look at how this fits
with FSx for NetApp ONTAP,
the primary storage is
still our vSAN datastore.
You could create an additional file system
and mount it to your ESXI host
and that could be either
using NFS or iSCSI
depending on the protocol
and it becomes your additional storage.
So for customers who do
not want to just increase
the number of hosts primarily
because of storage reasons,
you could have your
minimum number of hosts
and then work with either ISV vendors
or FSx for NetApp ONTAP
to increase the storage.
How does this look like?
So if you take a look
at this diagram here,
customer VPC is your VPC.
The EVS environment gets
deployed inside this VPC.
You can go ahead into your AWS account,
create a file share in
FSx for NetApp ONTAP,
and as long as you enable
the right security group permissions,
you have access to these file systems.
So this is using NFS, the
same architecture is available
for iSCSI as well.
You create the (indistinct)
and then have security group permissions
so that you can have
traffic going both ways.
The third building block is networking.
We've done a lot of work here.
I mentioned in the beginning,
when we deploy the
environment, we deploy it,
we take care of storage and networking.
What it also means is
traditionally, AWS has always been
a flat layer three network.
We have a VPC, you deploy a
cinder block, you have subnets.
Work great.
As we started to build
EVS, we also wanted to see
how do we bring this VLAN
subnet concept into VPC.
So we've taken care of that.
What we've done is, Andy
mentioned when he started,
there's overlay networks,
there's underlay networks, et cetera.
So as part of the deployment
we take care of that networking for you
so you don't have to worry.
All you have to provide us is inputs
on what your appliance IP
address spacing should be.
And a key part of that
is also using some of
the existing AWS features
that are available.
As you think about your EVS environment,
you probably are going
to connect on premises
to talk to a VMware
environment that's there
or you want to maintain
a hybrid environment.
So we've used the existing AWS
route server functionality,
think of it as a BGP
propagation mechanism.
What it does is you've got a lot of IPs,
underlay IPs, overlay IPs, et cetera.
This is like your VM IP
spaces or your appliance IPs,
so the route server basically
enables BGP communication.
It acts as a BGP endpoint
between your NSX Edge
and all your route tables,
propagates your route table
so you don't have to worry
about any of those failovers,
or like IP addressing going
in and adding static routes
into your route table.
And if you take a step back
of the full external connectivity,
you can have multiple EVS environments
as part of inner region.
You can also have other workloads
that you're running within
the same VPC as well.
And then I mentioned, all this connects
into a transit gateway.
And then from the transit gateway,
you could either have a direct connect
or a VPN connection back to
your on-premises network.
So it enables the full
end-to-end connectivity.
I'll quickly touch upon pricing.
So we talked about, Andy
mentioned we are operating
in a bring-your-own license
or bring-your-own subscription model.
So what do you pay for AWS?
The first one is the actual instance cost.
So this is the EC2 instance
that you're running today.
It's a four host minimum.
All your existing savings plan
and reserved instance concept
still applies to this.
This is a standard EC2 instance.
We're not doing anything
out of the ordinary here.
The second is that VPC
route server endpoints.
You do require two VPC
route server endpoints
per environment.
So you do have a cost that's
associated to take care of it.
And finally is the service
control plane fee itself.
This is where the service itself
takes care of the deployment,
the underlying connectivity
between your appliances
to RVPC space, et cetera.
So there is a hourly fee
built for this environment.
So these are three dimensions
that you will incur
as part of an EVS pricing model.
With that, I will pause.
It's always good to hear from customers.
So we've been working with
Jignesh from NYU Langone
for the last several months now.
I'd love to invite Jignesh to
share their journey with you.
- Thank you Aarthi. Hello everyone.
I'm Jignesh Shah, manager
of cloud engineering
over at NYU Langone Health.
I'd like to start off with a number. 320.
That's the average number of days it takes
for an enterprise application
to migrate to the cloud.
I'll be talking about how NYU
was able to bring that number down.
Little bit about who we are.
A large academic healthcare system
based out of New York City.
Our mission is to provide
world-class patient care,
in a way to research, and
a top-notch medical school.
And yes, the medical school is free
if you can manage to get in.
The three pillars.
Patient care, research,
and the the medical school,
you know, that's really powered
by the world-class technology
that we provide to support it
with the help of partners like AWS.
Some key facts and statistics.
We've been number one for quite some time
for the best outcomes.
Constantly ranked on the top
for several subspecialties.
Whether it's neurosurgery,
orthopedic, pediatric,
we are up there.
We have about five large
campus in the five boroughs,
along with close to
400 outpatient centers.
We see about 2 million
outpatient visits every day.
And in terms of number of employees,
we are close to about
53,000 in total employees.
So quite large academia.
Okay, so our adoption of EVS.
I remember it was few months ago,
you know, I was watching Monday
Night Football with my son,
I think it was Giants versus Eagles.
And I get a phone call from my boss
and he says, "we have to
go down from taking months
to weeks to migrate our applications."
So the first thought, you
know, I wanted to tell my boss
that "You're crazy, it's impossible."
And in turn, next morning we huddled,
I called my team.
And you know, we have
smart cloud architects,
security analysts, SRE engineers,
and I challenged them to find a solution
to accelerate our journey to the cloud.
And being a VMware shop on prem,
it was a natural transition
to go to something VMC in
one of the hyperscalers.
So we started contacting
different hyperscalers,
we came up with a
comprehensive success criteria
and it was really
detailed success criteria.
All the way from security
to chaos engineering,
we had everything in it.
Few months later, we had
a breakthrough with EVS
and I'll go through some of
the reasons why we chose EVS,
what resonated the most with us.
But first, our business case,
it was accelerate migration to the cloud.
How can we go from
months to just few weeks?
And also, can we leverage
cloud for business continuity?
As you can imagine, being
a healthcare system,
our uptime is absolutely crucial.
So business continuity
was one of the biggest use case.
Some of the business requirements.
We wanted to maintain control.
Like Aarthi and Andy mentioned,
we get administrative control
over the vSphere clusters
running in EVS.
We can bring our operational cadence,
how we patch, how we
monitor, observability,
security, we were able to extend
what we do on prem to the cloud
and make it more of a hybrid.
Flexible licensing model.
One of the requirements
was to bring-your-own license.
So we were able to bring
our existing VCF license
into EVS.
Multi-layer security.
Because we are able to run in our own VPC,
not only we could use
our existing security guardrails
like SCPs, RCPs, but we could also extend
our NSX security to the cloud.
It was really transformative
when we saw that that was possible.
Minimizing staff turnover.
One of the requirements
that our management had
was we don't want people leaving us.
Leverage existing skillset
and then slowly upscale as needed.
That was one, and then
EVS made that happen.
Obviously reducing capital expenditure.
You know, we wanted to
go from more of a CapEx
to an OpEx model.
So not having to spend to
buy hardwares and servers
or lease data centers.
EVS becomes an OpEx
model, is billed hourly.
We are able to cost manage it.
So that was one of the requirements
around reducing capital expenditure.
Why did we choose EVS?
Like I mentioned, we are able
to run this in our own VPC.
Some of the other competing solutions
we were tied into the vendor-managed VPC,
not giving us enough visibility or control
over what's happening behind the scenes
and what we could do.
Provisioning infrastructure as a code.
We are big into provisioning
everything as a code.
So we wanted to leverage
our existing CICD pipelines
for anything that we deploy in the cloud
and EVS had that offering.
I talk about bring-your-own VCF license.
Starting with a pilot light.
Another welcome and a great feature
of EVS is we can start
with a small pilot light cluster
and then we can add nodes as needed.
So you can start with as
small as a four-node cluster
and then you can add and scale up
as you migrate applications
or you put disaster
recovery workloads in it.
And on demand, we could scale out
the number of nodes in the cluster
in an event of a disaster.
Growing iOS ISV partners.
Because we are a heterogeneous
environment on prem,
it was important for us
to maintain the partner ecosystem
that we use on prem.
Whether it's pure storage
or it's FSx on NetApp,
we wanted to keep our
partner ecosystem intact
and have as little changes as possible
when we move the applications.
Automated security provisioning.
We are able to continue using
some of our security tools
that monitor communications and traffic
and they take action
when they see an anomaly
or a threat detection.
So we were able to leverage
and continue automating security.
And the last one is
one flat rate per node.
You know, we are really paying per node,
you're not paying per
VM or per EC2 instance.
We are able to run as many VMs as we wish
on a single EVS node
and that was really, really
useful to our use case.
Okay. Lessons learned.
Although this was a successful journey,
we did run into some bumps in the road
and with the help of AWS support,
the account team, and our OEM partners,
we were able to quickly
overcome some of those hurdles.
One was operationalizing EVS.
We had to figure out a way
and build a custom module
to integrate EVS
availability and performance
with our service management back on prem.
Things like monitoring
FSx NetApp performance,
or integrating Veeam with
our ticketing system.
There was a learning curve
and it took some time to
really operationalize EVS.
One of the issue we had was
figuring out network routing
between the EVS overlay
and the VPC underlay.
Because we have a
sophisticated network topology,
it took us a little while
to figure out routing
and put those policies in place
to get the overlay VMs working
with the underlay services, such as EC2,
as well as the on-prem applications.
Data ingress cost.
You know, AWS always
says "Data in is free,
data out will cost you money."
But in this case it was
a bit of a surprise.
But we did see some ingress cost
but we were able to work
with our AWS account team
and bring that cost in control.
And CloudFormation.
Because we are not a CloudFormation shop,
there was a learning
curve for the NYU team
to use CloudFormation to provision EVS.
Looking ahead.
Today EVS supports Single-AZ,
so we are looking forward
to a Multi-AZ support.
They already have multi-region support.
Looking forward to them
inviting and certifying
more ISV partners as this ecosystem grows.
And looking towards a
Terraform support for EVS.
And back to Aarthi.
- Thank you. Appreciate you
sharing your journey, Jignesh.
So we'll jump into a quick demo.
I'll walk you through the
actual deployment experience.
Okay, so this is the landing
page in the AWS Console.
So as you can see, when
you go into Get Started,
there's a few things
here before deployment
I think we wanna make sure.
There's a lot of information
we collect from you.
Business-level support is minimum required
as part of having EVS.
But we also wanna make sure
as you think about how to get started,
there's prerequisites.
So we provide you all this information
in terms of what
prerequisites are required
that helps you with planning.
Because most customers
that we've talked to,
their on-premises team and
their cloud team are different.
There's a separate network team
that handles like IP address spacing.
So it's important to understand
what these prerequisites are.
So you'll see all that here.
It's divided into like a
four portion of what we need.
EVS also interacts, as you
saw, Compute Network Storage.
It spans across other AWS services.
So we've provided links to other services
that you'll interact with.
So if you go into Environments
and go into Create Environment.
You'll see here, you'll
have to give a name
for your environment.
And then this is where we
collect some basic information.
We're starting with VCF version 5.2.1.
And then as part of your
agreement with Broadcom,
you would have a site ID.
So you'd given a site ID
and provide the solution key
and the vSAN license key.
It's important we do checks
for this solution key and license key.
What this means is you wanna make sure,
if you're deploying a
four-node environment,
you have enough course to support
as part of this key that you are having.
Once you've given the solution key
and license key, and then the next page
is where you deploy the host itself.
So these are the easy two instances.
This is the compute that
I was talking about.
The initial cluster, as I mentioned,
is a four hosts minimum.
And this is all deployed,
as Jignesh was talking,
in a single availability zone.
You do have other options
of choosing placement
group settings, et cetera.
But you can go ahead and
create all the four hosts here.
And then we go into the
actual Network Configuration.
We launched this feature very recently.
For customers that are familiar,
HCX enables you with migration of your VMs
from on premises into EVS.
And you could do it over
private connectivity
either using a direct connect
or using internet connectivity.
So both these options
are available for you.
So this is where you tell
us, "Hey this is my VPC
that I want the EVS environment to be in."
So you select your VPC.
And then you select what we
call a Service Access Subnet.
So EVS deploys it into your account,
so we will have a service access
into your particular
subnet that you choose
and what security group that you select.
And this is a subnet that we use.
And this model is very
typical to other AWS services
like the Network Load
Balancer or RDS for example.
Next comes the actual
VCF connectivity options.
We deploy these stacks,
which means we also take care
of deploying these management
appliances for you.
What we do is, and this is
part of the prerequisite
from an IP planning perspective,
is for you to give us
what cinder blocks are required
in order for us to use that
as part of the Cloud Builder deployment.
So once you get all those IP
addresses, as you can see here,
I've pre-filled some of these things.
And this is where you select
what that route server.
You would have to create
your route server endpoint
and tell us which route
server peering to use.
So you could select the
route server peerings here.
And then go into your Next.
And then this is standard DNS host name.
You could either use Route
53 or your on-premises DNS.
We ask for DNS host names
for your appliances.
So once you get your DNS host names
and the last page is just tags.
So you'll see, you'll have an ability
to review all these settings.
It's important to note
some of those IP addresses
for those appliances.
You cannot come and edit it.
So it's important to just be sure
you are filling in the right information
as you go through this.
So once you give us this,
we collect all of this
and our control plane, our service,
takes care of all this
bootstrapping this information
and deploying it for you.
The typical deployment time today,
it takes approximately three hours.
And this involves building the VCF stack,
getting the host up and running.
So at the end when you
see the environment,
when we hand it off to you,
you can immediately log into
your V center (indistinct).
Credentials are managed in KMS.
So I've just recorded this
so that I can show you,
but let me just show you an environment
that I've created to show.
This is an environment that I've created.
So you would see here
that the details of the
environment are here,
this is what you gave us.
So you gave us what the
hosts are, what the keys are.
So we go ahead, and you'll see
this is a standard EC2 instance.
It's got an instance
ID associated with it.
We deploy these hosts for you.
You will also see this
is where you provided us
your network configurations from your VPC
to what service access
subnet and route server.
And then you'll see the VLANs
that we've created for you.
So these are the 10 VLANs that Amazon,
you will see this in your account,
and these are created in a
special subnet that you see here.
And then the DNS host
names are also available.
- For anybody who's done
a deployment on premises,
these VLANs all probably look
very familiar to you, right?
This is the same thing
that you would deploy
in an on-prem environment.
So really, the difference here
is rather than racking
and stacking, cabling,
having your network team
configure everything,
you're providing just
the logical information,
the IP subnets, those types
of things, click and deploy.
But this is nothing kind of special
from a cloud perspective.
This is really the same
stuff you would use
in a on-premises deployment.
- And then you should be able to log in.
Once this is available in your
account, you should be able
to log into your SDC
Manager or NSX Manager
and continue your day two operations
like you would normally do.
So that wraps up our demo.
We do have a lineup of sessions this week.
And as I was talking earlier,
this is an introductory-level session,
but you can see here,
there's very specific
storage-based sessions or
networking-based sessions
that are related to EVS and
migrations throughout the week.
So feel free to take a look
at some of these sessions.
Some of the Chalk Talks are
not going to be recorded,
so I highly recommend doing
some of these Chalk Talks.
These are smaller sessions
where you can dive as
much as detail as you want
depending on what you have.
We do have a Getting Started Guide
and that Deployment Prerequisite Checklist
that I was talking about,
so take a look at it.
And Andy and I, we do
this session every year,
so if you have any feedback,
we take it very seriously.
So please make sure to
give us some feedback.
It should be available on the app.
We're gonna be hanging
out after this session.
We do have some time, so happy
to take some Q and A as well.
Jignesh is also going to be
here, so if you wanna talk
to any of us, come chat with us.
And really, really appreciate.
I know it's a long week.
There's a lot of other fun announcements.
The only AI we could include
in our session is Andy's couch.
- Okay.
- But there's a lot of good announcements
and keynotes coming up.
So appreciate all of you
showing up on a Monday morning
to this session.
Thank you.
- A couple of big takeaways
or things I just want you to
think about as you're leaving.
Like one of the questions
we get asked a lot
as we're talking with folks is like,
"When would I want to use this?"
And as Jignesh mentioned,
a key thing for when
you wanna consider EVS
is when speed matters.
Aarthi and I have conversations,
I think probably at least
once a week, if not more,
where customers say "My
data center contract
is coming up for renewal.
And I need to be completely
outta my data center
in six months."
Or, "My server support is
running up in three months.
And I need to be out of it very quickly."
So a big case for using
EVS, when speed matters,
when you need to move
from point A to point B
very, very quickly, this is
definitely the fastest way
to get from point A to point B
while maintaining all the kind of people,
process and technology aspects
of it that are the same.
The real secret sauce of this,
what allows us to happen
is you do not have,
we didn't cover this
tremendously in the networking,
but I would encourage you
to go to the deep-dive
sessions if you can.
Some of the kind of real magic of this
is the ability to actually
extend those layer two networks
from your on-premises
environments into the cloud.
This means you do not have to change
the IP addresses of the
VMs as you move them.
And when we talk with customers,
this is one of the biggest
things that they come up with,
is "If I don't have to
change the IP addresses,
it reduces my testing burden,
it allows my app teams
to do less work, and I can
move much, much faster."
Again, we were trying to
provide much of a higher level,
this is what it is and how it
works at a very high level.
If you can attend some of
those deep-dive sessions,
they'll go into a lot more detail
of some of the magic behind this
and being able to literally
use VMware's HCX technology
to move the VM from on
premises into the cloud
without changing IP addresses,
with very, very minimal downtime,
and being able to do that very quickly.
So encourage you guys to check that out
and I'll just echo what Aarthi says.
Thank you so much.
We would really, really appreciate it
if you could provide us feedback.
We hope you learned something.
And again, we'll hang out down here
and we're happy to answer
any questions that you have.
Thank you all. Have a
great rest of your week.
- [Aarthi] Thank you.